Estás cenando con tu mejor amigo:
una buena conversación, un buen vino,
unas costillas. Miras hacia afuera para admirar
la luna llena, pero cuando volteas te das cuenta
de que tu amigo se ha convertido en
un hombre lobo. Afortunadamente los
cubiertos están hechos de plata y sabes cómo
usarlos. O tal vez te estás bañando un día,
y cuando alcanzas el jabón notas una verruga en
tu dedo gordo del pie. Bueno, aplicas un poco de
nitrato de plata en esa cosa y en poco tiempo
estarás listo para la temporada de sandalias.
Brillante conductora de electricidad y muy útil,
la plata ha sido valorada desde la Antigüedad,
y tiene fama de ser pura y de alejar el mal,
ya sea en forma de hombres lobo o de verrugas.
La plata también fue un gran impulsor del
asentamiento en el oeste de los Estados Unidos,
incluso en Montana, donde yo vivo. Y por supuesto
toda esa plata llegó aquí debido a la Química,
específicamente está aquí por las innumerables
reacciones químicas que tuvieron lugar durante
eones, llamadas reacciones de precipitación.
Cuando los productos químicos en una solución
reaccionan para formar un sólido, las reacciones
de precipitación crean depósitos geológicos en la
Tierra, así como anillos en tu bañera. Es lo que
usamos para hacer que las aguas residuales sean
potables, y han sido utilizadas por personas
durante miles de años para hacerse ricas,
porque las reacciones de precipitación son una de
las mejores formas de producir productos químicos
de la más alta pureza. Entonces no sólo son
la respuesta a cómo se depositó la plata en
esas montañas hace cientos de millones de años,
también son la clave para recuperar esa plata.
Puedo hacerlo aquí mismo en este escritorio,
y todo lo que necesito para comenzar es esto.
Precipitación son cosas que se caen de otras
cosas: agua cayendo del cielo, sólidos que
caen de la solución. Para nosotros todo se
reduce a una cosa llamada solubilidad. El agua,
como hemos discutido antes, es bastante buena para
disolver cosas, compuestos iónicos en particular.
Un ion cargado positivamente y un ion cargado
negativamente, unidos por sus cargas, podrían
formar un cristal cuando están secos, pero agrega
un poco de agua y esas pequeñas moléculas polares
se van a deslizar entre los iones disolviendo
cantidades masivas de compuestos iónicos.
Pero algunos compuestos iónicos incluso pueden
superar el poder de disolución del agua, y cuando
se forman a través de reacciones y soluciones
caen como un sólido precipitado. Entonces las
ricas vetas plateadas en Montana se formaron
cuando el agua repleta de compuestos iónicos
corrió a través de grietas y pilares de piedra
caliza. Donde las condiciones eran apropiadas,
los iones plata en el agua reaccionaban con
compuestos iónicos o sales en la piedra caliza
para hacer compuestos de plata insolubles
que se separaban de la solución. Se parece
un poco a esto, en realidad se ve exactamente
así. Es genial, porque no puedes sentir esto,
pero es extremadamente pesado porque la plata
es un elemento bastante pesado. Y no fueron
sólo las sales de plata y la solución, todo tipo
de cosas se disuelven mientras que el agua corre
por el paisaje: sales de oro y potasio y cobre, y
especialmente sales de sodio. Si estos compuestos
disueltos permanecen en la solución hasta que
llegan al océano, prácticamente se quedan allí
para siempre: el agua se evapora dejando las
sales en el océano, donde en el transcurso de
los eones se ha acumulado haciendo al océano súper
salado como lo conocemos hoy. Y mientras que el
cloruro de sodio, lo que llamamos sal cuando no
estamos hablando de Química, es la sal más común,
también hay toneladas de otras cosas disueltas
en el océano, incluyendo bastante oro. De hecho,
a valor de mercado actual, el océano contiene
alrededor de 100 millones de billones de dólares
de oro, y eso no fue un tartamudeo: 100 millones
de millones, eso es 100 millones con seis ceros
más. Entonces podrías entender por qué sería bueno
dominar algunas reacciones de precipitación. Ha
habido químicos que se han vuelto locos tratando
de descubrir una forma no tan cara de extraer oro
del agua de mar, pero hasta ahora ninguno lo ha
logrado. Esta solución de nitrato de plata es
similar a esa agua rica en iones que se filtró
a través de la piedra caliza en Montana hace
millones de años, y podemos usarlo ahora mismo
en este escritorio para recrear las antiguas
reacciones que depositaron plata y vetas a través
de nuestro paisaje. Pero en lugar de los tipos de
sales que se encuentran en la piedra caliza
podemos usar un compuesto iónico muy similar
y sustancialmente más conocido: sal de mesa, el
viejo NaCl. Añade unas gotas de cloruro de sodio,
también conocido como agua salada, a la solución
de nitrato de plata y ahí tienes tu precipitado.
Oh, asqueroso. Ahora, la pregunta que queremos
hacer de inmediato es: ¿qué es esta cosa blanca
aquí abajo? La clave para entender lo que acaba
de pasar aquí es que ambos compuestos son iónicos.
Recuerdas que hay dos tipos de iones, ¿cierto?
Los cationes están cargados positivamente y los
aniones están cargados negativamente, al igual
que los pequeños imanes de barras se atraen,
de modo que los cationes sólo reaccionan con
aniones para formar nuevos compuestos. Y no
pienses que hay sólo un anión y un catión, el ion
sodio y el cloruro de sodio tendrán iones cloruro
en los cuatro lados, que a su vez están rodeados
por 4 sodios, y este patrón se repite muchas,
muchas, muchas veces, hasta que terminamos con los
cristales de sal que disolvimos en el agua. Pero,
¿cómo sabemos qué iones son cationes y cuáles son
aniones? Bueno, el sodio tiene carga positiva,
por lo que es un catión, y sabemos que está
cargado positivamente porque el sodio es un
metal que está en el lado izquierdo de la tabla
periódica y esos siempre son cationes cuando están
solos. La plata también es un metal y también
es un catión. Sabemos que el cloro es un gas
en el lado derecho de la tabla periódica, de modo
que es un anión. ¿Y qué hay del nitrato? También
es un anión. Nitratos, sulfatos y fosfatos son
realmente comunes y siempre son aniones. Cada
vez que veas un N, S o P seguida de un montón de
oxígeno, sabrás que estás mirando un anión. Con
eso en mente, mira los posibles productos de
esta reacción. Lo que buscamos es un producto
que no se disuelve en agua, así que sabemos que
no es cloruro de sodio, eso fue uno de nuestros
reactivos y se disuelve fácilmente en agua, de
ahí los océanos, y no es nitrato de plata, nuestro
otro reactivo, o nitrato de sodio porque como
regla los nitratos se disuelven muy fácilmente en
el agua. Entonces sabemos que está disuelto, así
que nos quedamos con cloruro de plata por proceso
de eliminación. Esto tiene sentido porque la plata
también hace compuestos insolubles con bromo y
yodo, que están en la misma columna de la tabla
periódica que el cloro. Los elementos en la misma
columna a menudo se comportan de manera similar.
Y notarás, por supuesto, que no terminamos con
una gran cantidad de plata pura aquí, ahora
está unida al cloro. Como la sal de mesa,
el cloruro de plata es un cristal y es sólido, sin
embargo, a diferencia de la sal, no es muy soluble
en agua. Ahora, sacar la plata de este compuesto
implica otro tipo de reacción, una acción redox,
óxido reducción. Hablaremos más sobre esto la
próxima semana. Mientras tanto, todavía tenemos
que aprender el lenguaje para describir este tipo
de reacción. Debido a las interacciones ordenadas
y únicas que están involucradas en reacciones de
precipitación, las sustancias disueltas producen
sólidos, iones que se disocian y se vuelven a
unir. Hay formas especiales de escribirlos y
equilibrarlos como ecuaciones. Una forma
es incluir anotaciones entre paréntesis
que dicen en qué estado están los químicos: "aq"
significa acuoso o en solución, y s para sólido,
lo que significa que es tu precipitado. Esto se
llama ecuación molecular. Otra forma que ayuda a
dar una imagen más clara de lo que realmente
sucede durante la reacción es escribir todo
como iones. Aquí se enumeran los compuestos
que se disuelven por completo en la solución
como iones. Esto tiene sentido porque tan pronto
como se disuelven las sales, cada ion está solo y
realmente no importa de dónde vino originalmente,
de modo que el lado izquierdo muestra iones plata,
nitrato, sodio y cloruro, todos en una solución;
y el lado derecho muestra sodio y nitratos todavía
como iones en la solución con el cloruro de plata
precipitado como sólido. Ahora no nos importa la
ecuación completa, sólo ver los precipitantes
activos, por lo que incluso podemos escribirlo
en una tercera forma. Simplemente dejamos de lado
los llamados iones espectadores, nitrato y sodio,
que no participan directamente en la reacción,
y terminamos con una ecuación iónica neta,
que muestra sólo iones plata y cloro reaccionando
para formar cloruro de plata. Esto es agradable
y breve y al grano, que es lo que los químicos
aman, porque recuerden: algunos de ellos tienen
habilidades terribles de escritura y tienen que
dictar sus cosas a sus mamás. Ahora, como una
nota al margen, ¿recuerdas cuando mencioné por
primera vez la rareza de usar Ag para denotar
la palabra "plata"? Bueno, eso se deriva del hecho
de que la palabra latina para plata es "argentum"
y los antiguos estaban como la mayoría de las
personas de hoy: obsesionados con lo que la plata
representa, no sólo riqueza sino también salud.
Los antiguos indoeuropeos asociaban la plata con
pureza y bondad. Hipócrates, el antiguo médico
griego, escribió sobre las propiedades de la
plata contra las enfermedades. Hay ciencia detrás
de los usos médicos de la plata. Muchos metales
son tóxicos para cosas como hongos y microbios,
pero a diferencia del plomo la plata no es tan
tóxica para los humanos. El nitrato de plata y
un compuesto llamado sulfadiazina de plata se
utilizaban para desinfectar heridas en la Primera
guerra mundial, antes de que se descubrieran los
antibióticos, la sulfadiazina de plata todavía se
usa para cubrir quemaduras, y los investigadores
ahora están analizando los usos antimicrobianos
de nanopartículas de plata. Algunas personas
incluso toman plata coloidal, básicamente son
partículas de plata en una suspensión líquida,
como una especie de refuerzo de salud general.
Pero en realidad no hay evidencia de que mejore
la salud, sin embargo, puede volverte azul. Ahora,
¿quieres esa plata aún más o no? Como siempre,
lo hacemos para que una reacción sea práctica,
tiene que ir al paso final de convertir la fórmula
de la ecuación en una ecuación de masa molar.
Si quisiéramos sacar la plata de la solución,
¿cuánta sal necesitaríamos? Específicamente,
digamos que queremos obtener una onza troy de
plata, la onza troy es parte del sistema de peso
Troy que se usa para pesar metales preciosos,
se deriva de la forma en que los romanos medían
barras de bronce y plata que usaban como monedas
hace 2,000 años, y todavía los seguimos usando.
Pero modernicémonos un poco en esto. Una onza
troy equivale a 31.1 gramos, de modo que queremos
31.1 gramos de plata, la masa molar de la plata es
107.868 g/mol. Hacemos el cálculo y encontramos
que 31.1 gramos es igual a 0.288 moles de plata.
De la ecuación molecular podemos ver que
para que se equilibre necesitaremos un mol
de cloruro de sodio por cada mol de plata, así
que para obtener 0.288 moles de plata, ¿cuánto
cloruro de sodio necesitamos? Lo hicimos fácil:
es 0.288 moles, después convertimos 0.288 moles
de cloruro de sodio en unidades de masa y gramos,
la masa molar del cloruro de sodio es 58.45 g/mol,
multiplica 58.45 g/mol por 0.288 y encontramos que
necesitamos 16.8 gramos de cloruro de sodio para
precipitar una onza troy de plata de la solución
de nitrato de plata. Y mira eso, obtienes un buen
montón de cloruro de plata en solución, sí no es
plata pura, aún no, al igual que los verdaderos
mineros que cavan en el suelo que contiene sólo
un pequeño porcentaje de plata, necesitamos hacer
algunos refinamientos. En nuestro caso hay otro
tipo de reacción necesaria llamada reacción redox,
redox es la abreviatura de reducción y oxidación,
y de eso es de lo que hablaremos la próxima vez.